E aí
[Música]
o olá você deve estar se perguntando
tipo de vídeo é este mas nem eu sei
responder pois
O que é uma coisa tão diferente não é
mesmo Júnior
e ele sabe que sim muitas pessoas querem
saber sobre a minha vida quero entender
como este rapaz de onde ele veio como
ele consegue estar em todos os lugares
ao mesmo tempo seria ele um novo bem ao
feltro
e eu não seria nada mais do que uma
pessoa que nem você cheia de
caraminholas na cabeça e é por isso que
tinha uma câmera atrás de mim e você não
viu você certamente não está vendo essa
aqui
é porque saiu agora da nossa cabeça e se
você vê o seu ponto de vista e você
consegue vir para cá e vê que aquele
quadro ali é feio demais
e às vezes parece um sapo às vezes um
acidente às vezes é um chapéu às vezes é
um sério é tão enigmático que eu deixo
ele aqui mas não foi eu que comprei não
As pessoas chegam e disse tão feio né Aí
eu lembro de mim me lembro do meu
potencial tu é
é exatamente como eu desprezado deixado
de lado humilhado jogado chutado com os
medalhados Mas no fim no fim toda essa
besteira e toda essa figura me deu tudo
isso
oi oi bonito põe depois e é por isso que
eu vou mostrar para você um pouco da
minha vida para você entender como eu
trabalho onde eu ando o meu anjo o que
eu faço o que eu como e 15 exames eu
faço na minha vida não é mesmo ainda aí
eu sou eu o Whindersson as pessoas não
entendem as vezes que tem que comer
mamão para carregar duro e é por isso
que eu vim falar para vocês sobre mim e
mostrar o meu dia a dia porque não
existe regra para sucesso mas muitas
pessoas me perguntam Wilson O que fazer
em e aqui que eu te respondo a água vai
pagar
E aí
e agora né não ser acreditar a cocada e
bora lá
E aí
[Música]
o humor humor comédia casa comediante O
Comediante é o acho que é o cara que só
faz comédia
tá ligado humorista eu já acho que é o
cara que mexe com a emoção por exemplo
eu acho que no meu show eu gosto daquele
momento da Luz um música tá ligado que
eu quero que a galera queria uma atenção
e fale Nossa que massa essa música que
engraçado nossa que inteligente essa
pasta já não então deixa eu vou ficar
aqui então Helen lawson ficar veiculado
todo mundo fica ali do lado mas se tu me
chamando que vai casar hoje é só mais
calma tu vai ser pode ser a última a
última depois de todos ganham novo uma
grande é assim ó só para apresentar e
tals
ah ah não ah gkay a GQ uma pessoa que eu
sempre coloquei muita fé né é eu acho
que tem que ter mais mulheres
comediantes é só jogar o colocar
qualquer pessoa para poder fazer tem que
ser uma pessoa que esteja disposta a
fazer essas um Gandu sabe essas coisas
assim que todo mundo tem vergonha de
fazer depois que as pessoas pergunta que
a dancinha e aquelas coisas de eu falo
com o cara me deu essas coisas aqui
então é trabalho é importante você tem
que encontrar uma pessoa que seja que
esteja disposta a pagar o preço para
fazer esse e ela é uma pessoa que faz
isso mas eu também tenho que ficar
convencendo de que ela é capaz sabe
mesmo uma pessoa com milhões de
seguidores mesma pessoa que tem
engajamento uma pessoa que tem todos os
pré-requisitos para fazer uma coisa dá
certo mas tem uma coisa em comum com
todos vocês que é a insegurança nós
somos inseguros regulador de Natal aqui
em cima alguns o
o bicho ele foi verdade foi para casa no
chão nada não vai trabalhar mas porque
era o primeiro dia e ele não sabia é
presente mesmo eu falar que eu sei o que
é que vocês têm aqui mesmo eu dizendo
assim na paz tá a galera ta ali de graça
a minha primeira noite aqui em São Paulo
foi o dia que eu cheguei de viagem e já
foi aquela atenção de tá aqui em São
Paulo e já pensar no show que era noite
quando cheguei no dia do show à noite
antes de entrar eu tava muito tenso pelo
fato de ser aqui em São Paulo a primeira
vez que eu saia do meu estado para fazer
um show para uma plateia também
diferente às vezes eu ficava naquela
coisa de por isso aqui no meu estado
funciona muito será que vai funcionar
aqui ele tem o Bruno Lima o que falar de
Bruno Lima para você que não faz ideia
de quem seja isso é uma coisa que
acontece muito muita gente fala comigo
como se me conhecesse e me conhece que
minha vida é um livro aberto mas eu
também conheço pessoas entendeu E esse
também pode gerar perguntas quem é essa
pessoa que não é
a rosa e o exame dela que é isso que
passa na cabeça das pessoas sabe puxa
ele pode estar falando agora com o Celso
Portiolli Por que que ele tá falando
comigo e o que é que eu vou falar com
Celso Portiolli meu amigo vai ligar para
mim vai dizer você troca esse
PlayStation por a linguiça eu sei não
tem assunto para tá falando com
celebridade Rapaz o rapaz rapaz tem que
conversar com as pessoas do seu tá
entendendo eu gosto do cara ele é meu
amigo é um cara esforçado eu conheço
desde muito tempo mas nesses dias de
teste o moleque tava igualzinho eu
conheço ele 2013 nervoso com medo e com
as mesmas piadas e aí que a gente traz
para casa né para ajudar a fazer a
cabeça andar o mesmo para 2016 então tu
tem que começar com as coisas de mim é
entrar com isso vamos dizer aí eu vim
para São Paulo exemplo é eu eu tô te
preparando para tu sempre saber entrar e
não entrar daquele jeito Pois é pessoal
20 apolinho Pois é gente vamos lá eu não
sou não mas não sou eu não faço isso não
show tu começa de
E é porque eu comecei outra paga esse
texto e sabe entrar ele quer situação
então por exemplo que vai eu e minha mãe
não gosta que eu tô em São Paulo tá
ligado em para poder tipo a minha mãe
minha mãe não gosta de nada para falar
vai abrir uma aí puxa entendeu tem que
habitou a plateia que tu tá falando de
mainha para tu não chegar não sei porque
esse material que o irmão uma exagerando
com outro tu vai fazer ele separado tá
seco aqui tu tem que arrumar um jeito de
começar ele e um exemplo é é o
e todo mundo faz de praxe né Tem alguma
mãe na plateia tá ligado Tipo tem alguma
tá ligado esse é o mais os amigos os
amigos de Alfonso del Mar
e tu pode aprender. Idelfonso edelmar
cara me deu força é bom e depois até
falou assim não viesse o terceiro deu
ruim hahaha é difícil é difícil você
encaixar o que você tá pensando na
cabeça de outra pessoa ou no busto a lei
é difícil tem que mostrar para pessoa
que é possível e que ela consegue é
muito difícil é por isso que às vezes as
pessoas pensa assim porque que o
Whindersson luta Box Mas na minha cabeça
a pergunta é por que que eu não lutaria
porque eu sou famoso Isso é um problema
quando as pessoas conseguem
reconhecimento ela sabe que estão sendo
vista para mais gente então o medo de se
expor ao ridículo vai começando a criar
uma parede na frente da pessoa
e vai achando que ela não pode fazer
certas coisas só que pode entender como
pode Pronto agora liguei abrindo hvsm
todos ver e tem Alfonso acabou de entrar
né então e o irmão é uma eu pensei na
frente do seu ruim problema é quando ele
tava sem por cento solteira ouvindo
Calcinha Preta Vol
e eu não consigo ficar um cachorrinho
Macho dela toda vida com carro
o carregador conheço
E aí
há muito tempo não para
E aí eu fui comprar as coisas para fazer
o quê
tu é 10 cada um aí eu tenho que desgraça
é isso que eu apaguei sem querer eu digo
teu aí
a considerar me livre tem coisa pano de
prato aí né cinco de culpa é dele pedal
50 seu de dentro 50 Tons de fraco e
quando precisa
e ainda tem aí é só um da doação agora
né galera só anda atrás de mim tem um
cabo chegou para mim não show de ser a
gente constrói o aeroporto em Floriano
de
é doida todo lugar cara eu sou um da
doação acabou onde eu vou eu vou cada
sinal que eu paro a 15 pano de prato que
eu tenho que levar para casa se eu
compro só dois estava fica zangado
ajudar aqui mão de dois aí eu calma
a compra tudo aí eu vou comprar tudo
cada assim na 15 final tem que levar
tudo depois eu chego em casa cheia de
pano de prato tangerina raquete mata
mosquito tudo que você pensar eu tô
comprando meio da rua cara tá vivo os
assuntos que eu falo as pessoas podem
interpretar de várias formas Por exemplo
agora eu tô falando que eu sou obrigado
a comprar coisa sem sinal e aí pode
parecer aqui ai meu Deus ele tá dinheiro
em dinheiro e ele tá falando que pessoal
do sinal vai pedir lá e ele não tem que
abrir o vidro na na na na verdade não é
isso é porque para mim na minha comédia
é muito mais fácil falar sobre o que eu
vivo Eu evito problemas sabe de fazer
piada com outras pessoas porque eu não
vou ficar me a vender para mim mesmo é
impossível para fazer comer mesmo porque
tudo que eu conto é de mim mesmo é de
mim mesmo se você ver os meus shows tem
uma progressão o meu primeiro show era o
quê mãe burra p****** tava era coisas de
mim mesmo naquela época era de mim mesmo
ver o segundo show já foi sobre
relacionamentos viagens entendeu era a
parte de mim que agora podia viajar
tinha condições de fazer isso E aí eu
conto tudo isso porque admin mesmo é uma
coisa de mim mesmo né
e eu não consigo falar sobre outras
coisas que não seja minha vida por isso
que às vezes a galera tira piada comigo
de rico e pobre a você só faz vídeo de
rico e pobre a você só faz coisa de rico
e pobre mas é porque naquele momento era
o que eu estava vivendo era um rapaz que
não tinha nada e do nada tinha tudo
então eu sabia dizer sobre as duas
realidades eu acabei de viver uma e tá
recente o suficiente para eu poder falar
sobre ela e tô vivendo outra aí tá
recente o suficiente para começar
aprender tudo sobre ela então para mim é
sensacional Comparar as coisas é
incrível mas essa fase passou por que
você vai ter no esclarecimento das
ideias entendeu Não adianta você fazer
as mesmas coisas sempre não perceber o
mundo ao seu redor eu percebi que começa
a ficar gritando te a diferença do que
eu vivo porque as pessoas vivem então eu
ficar comparando começa a ficar meio
estranho sabe mas eu percebi isso eu
percebi tem uma progressão no meu último
show Eu já falei sobre casamento sobre
Lua de Mel sobre mais viagens pelo mundo
porque eu percebi que a galera gosta de
ouvir
a viagem a galera gosta de saber vendo
começou o barulho ali nesse último show
percebi que a galera gostava muito de
viagens a galera gostava de ver pelos
meus olhos como era aquele lugar Às
vezes a galera não tinha vontade de ir
mas a garantia Vontade de saber o que
que o impulso acha daquele eu percebi
isso eu fiz já esse último show que se
chama a volta do que não foi já é muito
mais complexo esse show que eu comecei a
fazer com os meus amigos que eu reunir a
galera que eu comecei a me importar com
alguns assuntos é um show muito mais
profundo
E aí
o meu pai procurando sempre preocupado
papai eu vim lá da p****** em 2015
depois eu fui para as viagens depois eu
fui para relacionamento e agora eu fui
para questões que eu nunca pensei que eu
pudesse falar no palco depressão
quem é
é só isso só
e ainda que eu pensei que tinha alguma
coisa mais pesado só que eu vi que
depressão é a pior coisa que tem E aí eu
falo de depressão
E ai ai eu não gosto de rir muito com
muita força né porque aqui parecendo
aqueles dragão aqueles máscara chinesa
[Risadas]
esse Universo de tá aqui na casa do
Edson morando praticamente na casa do
Whindersson durante mais de 15 dias
mergulhado na comédia a gente respira
comédia acorda falando de comédia aí a
noite vai para um show textual que já
escreveu hoje de manhã para ver se vai
dar certo não dá tempo de esquecer
porque no outro dia à noite você já vai
para o palco novamente e a gente termina
o show já vem para cá para casa e já
conversa já sim coordenada pelo cheio de
pelo negocinho assim ó
E aí
e é bitburger o Bruno é sangue bom
demais cara tu é doida
e sobre o Buzz tempo
E aí
o Halloween da mais tarde e
o bairro dando cara passa correndo por
isso aqui ó Simone de mosquito entre uns
10 na boca de todos os meus amigos
trabalham comigo desde sempre estão
sempre comigo porque são pessoas que eu
conheço sei a loucura deles você vai
encontrar vários malucos no meio da rua
você vai encontrar vários malucos na sua
vida se você conseguir entender a
conversa do Maluco você vê que tem como
chegar algum lugar e eu ando com essas
pessoas malucas que estão querendo
encontrar o sonho delas também então a
fim de dar uma vida boa para a família
uma escola boa para o a criança uma
farda que não tem aquele negócio aqui
duro quando usa quarto ano também eu já
tive que usar esse outras pessoas olha
olha o banco dele é duro de pedra onde
suvaco dele ele usa rolon pessoas têm
preconceito com quem usa rolón e não uso
um aerosol
Bom dia de hoje velho basta chega a
a chamar meu amigo para fazer um pouco
aqui para vocês e escreva com muita
pausa muito carinho muita energia Robson
Souza forma para o Robson Alguém já
ouviu falar do clima de Teresina o
inferno que é lá Imagina eu aqui no fio
agora quando eu tô aqui um mês eu sair
de lá eu entendo avião estava 42°
cheguei aqui tava oito eu desci do avião
igual ser velozes ó ó
e quem ele era o significado para você
no passado e hoje você tá conhecendo nem
aí para muito legal recebeu o Tom o Tati
assistir um cara que tu teve como
referência a vida toda referência de
comédia fazer a personagem para fazer de
cara limpa fazer tudo cara é genial e
ele tá lá te dando um feedback do teu
short assistindo assim a 2m de distância
é incrível ele dado Finale foi super
legal foi no camarim conversar com a
gente pode ser legal bem vão menino
também tá aqui
o jogo notícia faz isso viu nada
e para criar você tentar os tem que
estar numa vibe de inspiração primeiro
mas Deus você chegar na frente do
computador pegar um papel e querer
escrever que nós sair para lugar nenhum
entendeu aí doce apertado tá descansar
na rua e aí você sentar comigo é assim
não adianta não é assim eu vou escrever
não é uma hora lá que dá Assim um
Violeta eu vou começa a produzir
entendeu a gente que a primeira tem para
falar de que ele deu primeiro primeiro
primeiro primeiro passou vivem para
começar primeiro tem que ter muita coisa
engraçada tem que uma coisa engraçada
que eu ganho um microfone sem fio e não
tinha microfone sem fio no Ceará ainda
nem nem Nordeste fiquei trouxe microfone
para mim foi o Edson Queiroz do Grupo
Edson Queiroz da Esmaltec em outros
estados unidos
e o que que velho desse jeito hein
Júnior
e por velha é vergonha de falar quem era
o dono das coisas que eles acho que a
gente lembra quem é o Edson Queiroz do
Grupo Edson Queiroz da Esmaltec sei lá
que tinha que vende Esmaltec
a cor de velha e aí é tanto que eu como
é que eu abrir o show eu abrir o show
que eu abrir o show do palco vazio e eu
falando escondido lá no shopping lá
muito boa noite e um prazer estar aqui o
povo tinha uma tudo para ver vou fazer
nada hahaha na prova de você pega aqui
procurando documento cada parece que se
você você que está de vermelho me
olhando eu escolhi ficar todo mundo é um
E aí
Eu acho que eu já parei aqui em São
Paulo se sou apressado né
o rapaz metrô fui pegar aqui para que eu
não sabia que você era tão apressada
assim eu ensino retorno tem escada
rolante inocentemente eu fiquei do lado
de cá é
e a pouca vi tanta gente com raiva de
mim ter uns 50 atrás e me xingando eu
tava lá sem saber de nada chegou maluca
atrás de mim no meu ouvido Segue o fluxo
tio
não tem comida no metrô né
cachorro-quente tudo de menino pediu um
cachorro-quente só cachorro quente aqui
é diferente eu falei completo cara
completo de completo ele botou purê de
batata
e vocês são doido
O que é bom para de batata conta Rocha
também bate fome feijão farinha Que
diabo é isso aí
e coloca voz também Aí eu vi a foto não
diz que eu veio essa muito nenhum e
outro sabe que é bom para sair nós que a
licença poética para poder falar tirar
onda com o paulista ainda empurrei aí
para levar eu vou botar arroz no alguém
vai levar trabalho feijão aí meu colega
que tipo assim agora tirando homem então
esse cara
e ele não acha com muita ligar mas eu
aprendi muito eu vi o show do
Whindersson e formar desde o começo eu
falei experiência para mim todo dia
escutar a voz se o que cachorro quente
batata doce Não sei o que dentro do
cachorro quente todo dia mas já tá
ficando doido já amor 15 dias na casa
doença eu respirei com média eu comi
comédia
e cadê a comédia fala porque muita
besteira agora olha a
Oi boa noite
[Aplausos]
Oi boa noite muito boa noite é
Oi amor então boa noite galera e São
Paulo palmas para vocês vieram aqui hoje
muito obrigado que legal hein cara que
legal eu vim parar aqui porque eu
administro nos clubes dele é Amei
bastante para mim é muito gratificante
ver a volta dele e depois de tudo que
ele tá passando de tudo que ele passou
então para mim é a maior felicidade dele
no palco fazendo que ligou só da Bahia
mas eu tô em São Paulo já fez quatro
anos desde 2016 é que eu tô aqui eu
fiquei em todos os seus dele que teve
aqui né Principalmente Assessoria sempre
me dar ingresso aí eu sempre ou e é uma
experiência incrível você aí né que
nunca foi no show dele próximo a cor
mesmo vai estar incrível faz superando
as nossas expectativas né Eu entendo fãs
sabe fãs é uma coisa que você tem que
entender como qualquer outra pessoa
porque eles são pessoas né eles têm
motivações a gente é formado
é aquilo que a nossa família viveu tá
ligado a gente às vezes acha que a gente
é todo cheio de problema é todo cheio de
coisas que a gente fala assim meu Deus
eu sou todo cheio de coisa para curar e
coisa para aprender e tudo mais mas são
coisas que nossos pais viveram nossas
mães e verão nossos avós e verão e vem
no nosso Geni tá ligado então às vezes a
gente olha para alguém e toma com uma
direção a gente toma como um Poxa que
legal cara eu gosto tanto eu quero ficar
eu quero ver tudo para mim eu sou assim
com The Rock p**** aquele rapaz eu vou
te dizer viu tudo que esse cara posta eu
curti isso é para você ver como o
algoritmo as redes sociais Elas têm um
padrão elas trabalham de uma forma mais
uma coisa que ela não pode e não
consegue de forma alguma simular a
cabeça humana e a cabeça humana meu
irmão é tão complexa que as vezes eles
gostam de uma coisa a ponto de que mesmo
e a rede social prejudique você vai lá
no sentimento Como eu faço às vezes não
aparece as postagens do The Rock para
mim sei lá às vezes é porque o cara dos
Estados Unidos eu sou do Brasil Às vezes
a rede soci
e aqui sei lá quem tem que ver quem mora
ali e aí não aparece as postagens do
carro pois eu entro no Instagram dele e
vou curtindo todas as 12 e postagens que
não apareceram para mim o burro burro
coração na de rock documento Como que o
Brasil p**** isso é nada mais nada menos
que a cabeça de um fã você toma pessoa
como uma direção e por isso as vezes a
gente tem tanta responsabilidade de
fazer com treino bom para vocês e coisas
boas para vocês acho que por isso que eu
tô falando esse tanto de coisa boa para
vocês porque eu quero que meus fãs além
de ficar rico se a noção da vida porque
dinheiro para o dinheiro não é muita
coisa não se você não souber fazer bem
com ele
E aí
que horror esse caráter muito muito boa
que eu disse que que aqui em São Paulo
cabos estacionamento fica assim ó
E aí faz um dia o cara fez isso aí na
frente dele tão pesado que ele entrou
ele é dizer eu entrei eu tava cara o
cara tava ela foi tão incisivo que ela
ficou com medo entrou hoje é
E aí
Oi bom dia já como é isso não é
é uma pegadinha logo cedo para ficar
esperto né e é para bordar que é bom
ficar dia de manhã sofá começar o
dinheiro ou ativa né
E aí
Em Julho eu acho que era o nada tudo bem
Tem problema não eu tô bem tô bem tô bem
ficou tudo certinho tudo não não não
teve problema nenhum só que ter os dois
dias que eu senti como se tivesse algum
lugar da cicatriz tivesse como vocês
inflamando onde leve assim faz um monte
de uma coisa eu vou ter uma se sentir
assim nós ficar três inteira É só tipo
no lugar onde era onde tinha o que é o
nome daquele negócio é o tic de um
abscesso é onde tinha ali que ele ele
fechou bem direitinho essas coisas que
ela cicatrizes assim bem na pontinha
dele assim eu sinto tão bom coisa de
piauiense né se sente só uma coisinha
assim o negócio tem assim umas coisas é
como se fosse assim assim lá na
piauiense adora isso como eu sei disso
prestando atenção nas pessoas meus
amigos vocês não presta atenção no dia a
dia não vai abrir a cabeça para
criatividade Tem que olhar
as coisas entendeu eu pensei você que o
Piauí é toda vez que ele chega ele
doutor é assim são assim como se fosse
uma pontada sabe aqui só assim é como
não quer você pega assim mas ele não
fala nada de estudo aqui quando você nem
nem para cá não era nem nessa vai para
outra tá ligado que ele não lembra nem
aonde era a dor dele é só confusão na
como se fosse assim um era mais ou menos
assim bem prima
E aí
a senhora quer dizer não não brincadeira
hahaha
o cara E adivinha o que a gente foi
fazer em você não sabe a gente foi voar
de paraquedas sem paraquedas porque o
meu medo maior não é o paraquedas
paraquedas na minha costa eu acho legal
o meu milho é altura então a gente foi
voar de paraquedas Sem falar que quer
dizer é
[Música]
E aí
[Aplausos]
eu não tava massa que eu tô com a
mãozinha assim faz um pouquinho fazer o
que eu sempre trabalhei desde cedo 16
anos aí eu nunca tive essa oportunidade
de viajar muito muito preso outra outra
vida outra entendeu no Brasil tá a fim
de andar de um
tá na hora de dormir não é
eu fui sou eu Paulinho Paulinho Olha meu
amigo Fred falei mas é
Oi e aí
E aí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a localização dele fala para ele que
quando eu quando eu tiver eu vou fazer
mais filmes eu vou pedir ajuda dele Será
que foi o vídeo seu tio a melhor
conversando sobre ó foram ou vacilo que
tu deu que ter deixado a tua voz falando
em português no início é para deixar sem
como se fosse eu falando em português e
ele em inglês e eu entendendo e ele
entendendo igual o programa do Danilo
Gentili quando o Wolverine vai lá né o
Hulk Jackman as pessoas perguntam
Wolverine você tem essas garras mesmo aí
ele faz assim ó
a 99 we don't I don't have this girls
girls fun to regain que que significa
que ele diria que os meus amigos que
estão começando a comédia do Five Night
and Day
Oi gente vai unir s636 é possível claro
isso você tem 300 e tantos milhões não
sei que visualizações seguidores não sei
que lá mais fundo eu assistir As
Branquelas não fazia nada e eu só
estudava e era uma pessoa eu nunca
pensei na minha vida nunca pensei Eu
Marlon esse ia ser meu amigo ele ele tem
meu número ele ele manda quatro a pro Aí
eu mandei digo e repito
Eu não duvido mais de nada para mim foi
sensacional trabalhar com cara porque eu
recebi uma dica muito boa que eu quero
passar para você aqui também não quero
de forma alguma deve ter conhecimento
para mim eu quero que você Também saiba
uma coisa que ele me falou Eu acatei e
minha vida começou a melhorar depois
disso faça as coisas do jeito que você
quer fazer se você quer filmar assim vai
aparecer um monte de gente falando não
mas é porque esse aqui mas aí tem que
ele vai balançar mas aqui o parafuso vai
saltar mas é que não sei que você fala
assim ó eu quero assim vamos procurar
soluções como aí vamos fazer assim e aí
você faz do jeito que você está pensando
em
o que eu vou tirar se a minha vida é um
livro aberta e as pessoas sabem tudo
para que tirar se era uma coisa passada
Esse é passado está gravado
é porque não mostrar com as pessoas
O que é
e me surpreendi que ele falou um pouco
de porta dele eu entendo eu estou tipo
Nem eu entendi tu falando em português
veja e aí a gente falando eu disse do
tipo o meu inglês vai aparecer português
ele sabe aí ele falou tipo cara a gente
podia fazer um show que aí que tipo eu
faço meia hora de show aqui no Brasil e
tu faz lá tá ligado Tipo na Netflix a
oi oi Lali e
meu Deus do céu
E aí
[Música]
eu tava gravado né galera não vou gastar
dinheiro à toa com a lente desta câmera
tão maravilhosa esse rapaz tão
maravilhoso este outro rapaz tão
maravilhoso aqui do meu lado fosse e não
colocar as imagens e foram trabalhadas
aconteceu aconteceu o que está
acontecendo acontecido por que que eu
mostro essas coisas de mim mesmo eu sou
assim eu sou uma pessoa muito de mim
mesmo é de mim mesmo mostrar para as
pessoas aquilo a pessoa para se
apresentar aqui para vocês recebeu com
muitas Palmas Apareça aqui do lado para
saber quem é que eu não sei a sequência
ele o Xavier Neto palmas para o Chávez
negou a
Oi boa noite eu tava no restaurante aqui
em São Paulo aí eu gasto não chegou para
mim e perguntou se eu aceito uma bebida
eu falei aceito Jesus Ele respondeu à
glória a Deus valeu valeu tchau
e eu vou aí não meu amigo eu aceito
guaraná Jesus você tem ele falou o rapaz
guaraná Jesus tem não Ah então me traga
o diabo da Coca mesmo
e o Xavier né Xavier é essa figura aí
que você tá vendo É é assim um cartoon
né Ele parece um cartoon ele é todo
avantajado aí você vê ele os olhos são
avantajadas ele avantajado é feio né
Xavier é só assim não é questão de nada
não ele também tirar onda comigo não tem
problema tá mas é que assim Às vezes a
gente tem que reconhecer ela Xavier
aquele quadro ali não
um de nós quando a gente começou perder
vai ficar aqui dentro até o final é
e tu viu eu tô feio não foi que arrastar
aqui é que você fizer dele mas o Xavier
de nós era o que mais seguir a regra e
talvez por isso deu uma parada no tempo
porque as regras são criadas por quem
vive naquele tempo depois o tempo vai
passando as regras têm que ser adaptada
porque senão se não cara não dá então
ele diz que fazia era o que mais se
ligava no morro de fora no morro
britânico no morro daquilo no morro dali
e às vezes esqueci que o motor tá nessas
coisas aqui
e essa madeira aqui mais veio para
aprender veio para curtir veio para
brilhar quando você tá disposto as
coisas acontecem não é
o edifício fica mais rápido e fácil não
o Google que tu não velho ah não é
G1
e o negócio que eu falei o cara vem com
vontade já chegou tão perto cara demora
um pouquinho sei que segunda entendeu
o wi-fi e
G1
o teste piadas 1
e o gato é três horas da manhã em cima
do quarto da gente cara querendo dormir
ele uma ó
Oi gata não é a mulher transando
atrapalhando Desse gato
os seus limites Não né Esse é uma com a
minha grande amiga burra para cobrir
isso mas vamos porque minha mãe
compartilha tudo qualquer coisa tá
compartilhando só demais dos outros
nesse cara nem sei quem é é porque sua
tia compartilhou e completo né tia tenha
sido bigodes e até que legal e toda foto
que eu posto Ela comenta muito bonita
minhas me ligue qualquer foto tá uma
foto que eu postei Esse dia eu falei
muito bonita me atende e pai no WhatsApp
é sempre aquela mesma coisa
E aí
Oi pai eu tô pegando fogo
já acabou sou um cara comediante faz
stand-up tem uns 10 anos não sou tão
famoso ainda no Brasil mas na minha rua
não está muito famoso porque eu sou um
chama de vagabundo uai vamos lá nos
cobre amor o morro de escola gente tem
duas opções ou essa sofrer bullying ou é
sofrer bullying na escola ou ia ser
engraçado né de apanhar para fazer graça
né fazer então das coisas mais incríveis
que eu acho de um show de stand-up e
principalmente desse show que a gente
construir juntos que foi uma galera se
uniu amigos dele do Whindersson e tal é
a reação que ele tem na proposta da
piada e uma das coisas que eu mais gosto
porque você fala da piada só para falar
tem uma tem uma versão mas você fala
piada com a Olha aí a girafa veio e não
sei o que acaba desse único problema
aqui é barulho
os animais não gosta de barulho é só
ficar em silêncio ficou em silêncio nada
acontece de graças a Deus acaba ligou o
carro vai lá acabou acabou vou morrer
hoje acabou história adentrando dentro
do safari eu morrendo de medo sabe com a
cor mais diferente que tem no Safari
aqui quando você tá assistindo pela
televisão e vocês ver os bichinhos
parecendo de frente
sim mas quanto tá num carro no meio da
selva eles podem vir de qualquer lado
então a qualquer momento aparece um
animal qualquer perto de ti quem tiver
olhando para trás funciona Ai ai
a entrega do corpo o som a luz tudo que
ele faz assim algo suas com mais prédio
também na qualidade do show de ter um
show entregue para ver se eu faço de
Carvalho parece que eu tô dentro do
universo e aí você ri você riu pessoas
em casa Imagine meu Deus as vê brincando
aqui fora e você vai viajando Você tá
pirando então para minha carreira para
minha vida para minha história eu vou
lembrar lembrar um aprendizado de união
de pessoas juntas e pessoas que fazem um
complô para que aquele texto não vire só
apenas um texto e vira uma coisa que as
pessoas entendam que você quer passar
com piada e Rio uma pensando Putz
arrepiei da sapatão na minha época era
sapatão não é p**** porque a gente mal
tá Sapatão a gente pode rir e se
divertir isso é todo mundo igual Então
essa é a lógica então ter esse show
pronto terça ajuda de a
é perto faz todo sentido porque faz tudo
virar ainda mais legal e mais
profissional e muito mais prazeroso você
me respeite viu Hum
e não é
é muita coisa O quê agora segue do da
Saudade calma safado tá muito massa
legal né que tá tá tudo bem tá igual a
sério borra Velho você sabe que os
bichos você mitando ficou para o caraca
André meda sério você fala muito e
e a fazer um
E aí
[Música]
E aí foi boa foi posta a cara do boleto
não foi muito bom do boleto velho pagar
um boleto para todo mundo aí
o que eu posso ir ao Faustão que nós
dois cara eu parei para pensar agora
nesse ti que eu tava assistindo essas
imagens e eu percebi o que que é porque
eu tenho um gastura para quem não
conhece para quem é de fora e não sabe o
que a gastura é um rapaz traz tem outras
pessoas que não sabe o que é que o revés
trás é como se fosse um bolo que tem um
símbolo é uma anemia Catarina o pé do
nariz eu tenho tanta agonia de catarro e
pendurados no nariz ou babinha no canto
da boca que toda vez que alguém dá o
play no uma câmera o Play não eu falei
assistindo né Toda vez que alguém dá um
rack uma câmera eu fico pensando assim a
parte alguma coisa pedi ao meu marido só
vou saber quando esta m**** tiver acabar
de filmar aí eu fico todo tempo é e não
tem nada aí o que acontece em vez de ter
uma imagem limpa sem catarro no nariz tá
e eu o tempo todo
e bota na mão no nariz mas eu não sou
assim todo tempo eu tô fazendo isso no
vídeo não tô percebendo tu não né não né
não eita fiquei com medo agora disso eu
hipócrita ai ai muitas pessoas também me
perguntam Wind de onde você tira tantas
piadas de onde você tira tantas ideias
de onde você tira Tanta Coisa Nossa é
tanta criatividade né às vezes essa
pessoa que conversou isso que tá indo
todos para mim me deu uma ideia e não
sabe sabe de onde aquele as ideias das
pessoas um grande amigo meu uma vez
responder uma pergunta a uma jornalista
Ela perguntou assim em quem você acha
que eu ainda sou se inspira aí ele falou
assim na família dele um monte de maluco
monte de doido e eu dou conversa para
maluco maluco tem história hein tu é
doido maluco tem coisa acrescentar eles
falam E você vai abrir na cabeça e vai
lembrando de várias coisas que você não
lembrava e tudo mais e aí sabe o que que
eu faço Sou Humano como qualquer pessoa
a nosso isso eu não anota na história
que eu tô escutando no meio da rua mas
às vezes o que a pessoa me fala me dá um
estalo para poder criar
as coisas entendeu E é muito difícil as
pessoas estarem no mundo real as pessoas
elas não veio mundo ao seu redor ela só
vê quem não quer ver ela vai falar com o
empresário ela passa por recepcionista
ela passa por motorista ela passa por
faxineiro ela passa por todo mundo não
conversa com ninguém esquece o mundo ao
seu redor chega lá não sabe nem as
perguntas certas para fazer porque tem
que saber as perguntas certas para
chegar algum lugar chega pelo menos com
esse tanto de milhões de seguidores e
fala como foi os primeiros vídeos mas
não seria melhor você chegar sem falar
Whindersson eu tenho certeza que você já
quis desistir porque todo mundo quer
desistir de qualquer coisa alguma hora
as pessoas querem desistir mas quando
você quis desistir o que fez você não
desistir fui alguém foi uma palavra que
te disseram foi uma coisa que veio de
você aí já gera várias perguntas esse
dentro de mim mesmo e eu quero responder
essas perguntas não para quem tá
perguntando para mim o que foi que me
fez não desistir você me gera um
questionamento que vai te gerar uma
resposta sensacional Então o que eu faço
é Todos esses tá luizinhas que eu tenho
durante o a
e eu vou anotando aí as vezes eu tenho
um estalo sobre avião eu vou lá e anota
piadinha curto uma besteira mas eu vejo
assim tem potencial assim igual esse
quadro aqui ó mostra esse quadro aí
o portão cerveró mas tem alguma coisa
fala assim tem alguma coisa ali aí eu
penso que não vai surgindo mais piada de
avião máscara de avião eu nem vou
procurar naquela nota ou simplesmente
abrir uma nota moto avião que leva o que
eu tenho para escrever e deixa ali
muitas vezes eu já vendi em várias datas
de shows em ter um show então preciso
fazer um show eu pego todas essas notas
pesquiso tudo que tem sobre avião e pode
ser que dali sai 17 um trechinho né
sobre avião e às vezes viraliza às vezes
vai ter uma página às vezes fica só ali
no YouTube e-mail entanto a
possibilidade que pode acontecer mas é
assim que eu faço Vou juntando juntando
na paciência na calma não senta para
escrever alguma coisa porque é o meu
método né Tem pessoas que são boas
sentando para escrever entendeu
e tem gente que é muito bom sentado
E aí
Ah eu pensei que você pensou em
e foi um graveto Ai ai esse tema com
aplausos todos os meus amigos no palco
vamos para Robson Souza Bruno Lima todo
mundo come Barros saneamento muita
mulher atrás de você e até a próxima
E aí
a próxima vez os outros
[Música]
e o cara foi isso que aconteceu a gente
criou um show desde agosto de 2019 até
agora em 2020 fizemos esse show ele foi
sensacional eu comecei a rodar com esse
show ganhar dinheiro com esse show
comprar esta banheira com este show e
fiz até uma turnê mundial que foi
interrompida pela pandemia coronavírus
bota imaginar pela da PM e
E aí
em shows e não sendo cancelado posto de
Coronel
E aí
[Música]
Ah mas isso você vai assistir na parte 2
isso aqui que só vai acontecer se você
não esquecer de clicar em gostei agora
bebê clica em gostei porque dá tanto
trabalho e fazer essas coisas eu sei que
quando você vê isso aqui a vontade de
dar o like diminuir porque eu sou assim
também tá Neymar postou de garra Neymar
acima de mim que tu quer meu like hora
dessa a dar um tempo né Neymar mas ainda
se eu posto a foto de lei se você puder
clique em gostei com leite aqui embaixo
o que que você aprendeu com este vídeo
comente aqui embaixo o comentário
e se inscreva no canal tamo junto é nóis
Boa diversão e não esqueça de assistir
meu show na Netflix adulto os meus dois
shows aqui no YouTube mas menino e o
proparoxítona E não esqueça de assistir
o meu próximo show que vira aí chamado é
de mim mesmo para vocês logo mais se
deve ser aí e clique em gostei
tá ligado né
e eu não tô pagando rodando não Júnior
não sou maluco da cabeça não tem
microfone aqui Eu tenho noção não vou
queimar o equipamento Pessoal peço que
só porque eu tenho dinheiro o queijo as
coisas quer joga no chão a cai meu
celular pa mas para você para nenhum
pegar para ver se quebrou a tela pois eu
fico triste mas passa tanto faz né vai
assim não é assim que as coisas
acontecem não dá um like aí gente tem
valores de pagar a
e você pode comer uma manteiga com
queijo na panela vai cantar mais não é
[Música]
E aí
Tá pronta já tá aqui já tá aqui agora
colocar para mim
Oi Oi bonitinho um
E aí
a obra meio mas colarinho por e-mail é
e eu tô vendo assistir Dez Mandamentos
Já cheguei lá sabe o que é engraçado que
do nada parece um carioca né Belém 1500
de Cristo tapioca com nada chega no meio
da guerra que tinha verificar ele assim
mas está perdendo de vaqueiro Mateus e
E aí